good morning John I'm kind of a
Sidelines fan of a very complicated
competitive card game that I started
playing in the '90s called Magic the
Gathering I don't really understand it
anymore but I do watch people play it on
YouTube and I kind of follow Magic news
and one thing about magic is that each
card since the game was created in the
1990s has featured a piece of art
created by a human artist and that's
created like a strong and interesting
relationship between artists who make
fantasy art and the company that makes
this game because of that this company
which is now inside of other larger
companies of course has said that they
will never use AI generated images as
art for cards recently the magic the
Gathering Twitter account posted this
image featuring reprints of some of the
cards talking about how great they look
and I agree they do look great but the
focus immediately shifted to the
background image which if you know very
much about images created by generative
AI this looks like that somewhat wildly
the Twitter account then doubled down
saying No this is definitely made by a
human we promise which is like weird
because that means that somebody looked
at this and they were like yeah that
seems like it was made by a person so
for whichever person that was and also
everybody else who might be interested
let's take a quick look at how you might
be able to identify an image that was
created by generative AI I really just
have three simple steps number one look
at the image and think about how it
would have been created is this a
photograph is it a 3D model is it a
digital painting if this was a world
before generative AI I would have been
forced to think that this must be a
composition position of one or more
photos along with possibly some stock
photographs also maybe likely some
digital painting in the background but
who knows a lot of things are possible
maybe it was made for some other reason
and then repurposed for this whatever
step two don't look at the image as a
whole look at little bits close up why
are these little things coming out of
this thing what is going on with these
lamps do they have two sets of filaments
why do they kind of blend into each
other these wires make no sense and the
gauge yes the gauge a I is currently
terrible at letters and numbers but
these are super crisp except like over
here where they are not almost like the
gauge was super messed up and then
someone photoshopped a real gauge on top
of it and oh my gosh look after a quick
reverse image search I found the exact
gauge that was used to do that but the
final step and I think the most
important one is to recognize that none
of this matters it doesn't matter for
two reasons first because these models
are just going to keep getting better
and whatever tricks you're using right
now to figure out if an image is created
by artificial intelligence you will not
be able to use those tricks in even one
year but the second reason it doesn't
matter is the more important one and it
is that we are not going to closely
scrutinize each one of the hundreds of
images that we come across every day now
we do scrutinize something when it
raises a red flag and there are a few
reasons why that might happen it might
kind of look like AI art to us because
we've seen a lot of previous AI art and
then we might look closer we might
scrutinize it because Magic the
Gathering is owned by Hasbro now and we
don't really trust them with the thing
that we have loved since 1995 but often
times no Flags go up and you just accept
it like this was the story of the puffer
pooke yeah if you look close his chain
disappears his glasses are all messed up
he's holding like a syrup bag but at a
glance that just looks like the Pope in
a custom puffy coat now if you think
about the pope a lot you're going to
think to yourself that doesn't seem like
something the pope would do but most
people don't think about the pope a lot
so we don't know what he would do it
just looks like a funny thing and then
we move on with our day the question of
the modern day is not whether we can
figure something out once we choose to
scrutinize it the question is when and
why do we choose to scrutinize things
which If We Vibe with it in whatever way
we generally choose to not do and that's
not just an AI image generation problem
that's an everything problem the mag of
the Gathering Twitter account later
confirmed my suspicion which is that
they had trusted a vendor who had told
them that it was not generated by AI but
it was and if you're wondering why why
this was such a big deal to a lot of
people there are a lot of reasons that I
am more and more convinced by that
despite the fact that AI image
generators are super cool and fun to use
they are not necessarily like going to
be a good thing at least the way they're
currently operating for the most part I
don't have time to get into it right now
but I would like to maybe get into it in
a future video because it is I think
both fascinating and important John I'll
see you on Tuesday in the 24 hours since
I recorded the first part of this video
the temperature in Missoula has dropped
from like 30° to -11 and that's why I'm
dressed like this now but I wanted to do
a quick message for anybody who might
have $500 or more to donate to make the
world a better place and you also want
to amplify the impact of that donation
because right now the project for
awesome matching fund is open and it
closes in about a month during the
project for awesome we have a system
where every time someone donates a
dollar then another dollar gets donated
from the matching fund and we build that
fund up from people who have enough
extra money to donate a substantial so
if you have $500 or more to contribute
to that effort there's a link in the
description and I'll have a bunch more
information about the project ver aom
for you next week cuz things are going
to be a little bit different this year
not like a huge amount but enough that
I'd like to talk about it in a video and
I'm going to be in Los Angeles next week
and i' tell you about all the places I'm
going to be but I everything has sold
out thank you I can't wait to see
everybody who comes out to the shows
John I already said that